what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video before we get
started I just want to let everybody
that enter the giveaway know that the
first prize winner has been picked at
random and I will announce your name at
the end of this video so make sure you
stay until the end so you can claim your
prize I am giving away three different
items so if you haven't entered the
giveaway yet there is still plenty of
time to win something the link will be
down in the description if you're
interested in that but let's discuss
varus and what I think will happen to
him by the end of the game of thrones
television series I am currently in the
process of making my death prediction
videos as most of you know by now I
already released in my part one video
which had about five or six characters
that I predicted would die next season
but as I was making my list for the part
two video I started to think about this
character some more and how I think he
will die this death has the potential to
be a little bit more interesting than
some of the others so I figured I better
make this a standalone video that way I
can show you some clips too without
making it too long I hope so let's start
the video off with one of the most
recent red flags that indicated Varys
will not survive the Game of Thrones
I would only be a distraction if I
stayed so where will you go
volantis good if you don't mind my
saying I don't think you should return
to Westeros I'm not sure you'd be safe
here
I will return their Spyder one last time
my lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you as you can see
Melisandre scared the [ __ ] out of Eris
when she said they were both going to
die in this country now obviously
everyone has to die someday but the way
Melisandre said that made it feel a
little bit more personal as if she knew
exactly how and why Varys would die ever
since this scene took place in season
seven many people have wondered when and
how Varys would die now that Melisandre
pretty much confirmed his death so the
big question is what is going to lead to
varus's death
how will he die or what will happen that
will cause his early demise I think that
answer basically lies with Melisandre
herself or I should say the red God also
known as real or it's no secret that
Varys has had this strange connection
with the red God ever since he was a
little boy I'm sure most of you remember
the story when Varys was just a child
a sorcerer cut off his genitals root and
stem and he tossed them in the fire and
then Varys heard a voice from the flames
a voice that has haunted him for the
rest of his life he burned my parts in a
brazier the flames turned blue and I
heard a voice answer his call
I still dream of that night not of the
sorcerer not of his blade I dream of the
voice from the flames was it a god a
demon a conjurors trick I don't know but
the sorcerer called and a voice answered
and ever since that day I have hated
magic and all those who practice but you
can see why I was eager to aid in your
fight against Stannis and his red
priestess a symbolic revenge of sorts
whatever Varys heard in the flames
terrified him something that Varys has
never forgotten and in my opinion
whatever it was that Varys heard could
not have been anything pleasant and I
think it may have something to do what
Varys his fate I think since the night
Varys are the voice in the flames he
knows his own destiny and it has kept
him terrified for his entire life and
it's one of the main reasons he hates
magic and any red priestess he has ever
came across just like Varys said in that
video clip with Tyrion that's why he was
so eager to help him during the Battle
of Blackwater Bay he was hoping Stannis
and Melisandre would be killed
he hates the red priestesses because he
knows one day they are going to be
playing a part in his downfall
Melisandre or even can vara will play a
role in his death I think that was made
pretty obvious after Melisandre said he
would die in this country because she
knows how he is going to die because she
will most likely play a role in his
death when she comes back from volantis
but we also need that closure with can
Varro can vara gave us another big clue
as to how Varys will ultimately die do
you remember what you heard that night
when the sorcerer tossed your parts in
the fire
you heard a voice call out from the
flames do you remember should I tell you
what the voice said should I tell you
the name of the one who spoke
[Music]
we serve the same queen if you're her
true friend you have nothing to fear
from me
ken vara also scared the [ __ ] out of
Eris and ever since Varys heard the
voice in the flame he has probably been
hoping and praying that it was not true
he doesn't want to believe what he heard
but kinvaras is a reminder of what
happened that night when she asks Varys
if he wanted to know what was said in
the flames this terrified him because
his greatest fear is coming true all of
the series of events that have taken
place in his life is leading him to his
demise and I think the voice in the
flames told Varys how he would die but
he doesn't want to believe it to be true
but conveyor is the truth that he does
not want to face he did not want her to
repeat what was said in the flames
because it's not something that he wants
to be reminded of and think about what
else can vara said to Varys in that
scene she said they both serve the same
queen they both served in eros and if
Varys is our true friend then you have
nothing to fear from me but something is
going to happen in the final season that
makes Varys no longer Daenerys is true
friend Varys will betray her and this
will lead to his death and Melisandre
has already seen this in the flames as
well that's how she knows he's going to
die and when Melisandre comes back from
volantis
she might have conveyor with her and
this is when Varys will be exposed for
who he truly is in the end Varys says
betrayal was already set up in season
seven episode two at the very beginning
of the episode when him and Daenerys had
their conversation in the war room one
Dragonstone swear this to me Varys
if you ever think I'm fading the people
you won't conspire behind my back you
look me in the eye as you have done
today and you'll tell me how I'm failing
me I swear it my queen
and I swear this if you ever betrayed me
I'll burn you alive I would expect
nothing less from the mother of dragons
Ken vara foreshadowed varus's betrayal
in season six in Daenerys foreshadowed
his betrayal in season seven
Littlefinger and Varys played the game
like living legends but by the end of
the series both of them will be dead
even they couldn't survive this deadly
game Varys will be heading north with
John and Daenerys to prepare for the
White Walkers but something is going to
happen that will cause Varys to turn
sides and betray Daenerys he'll bran
might even play a role in his death -
bran could possibly warn Daenerys that
she has a traitor in her camp but deep
down I think it would be Melisandre or
conveyor who will ultimately expose
Varys and he will be burned alive just
like Daenerys had promised him if he
ever betrayed her like I said at the
beginning of this video Varys has had
this connection with whirl or and fire
ever since he was a boy his story more
or less began with his genitals being
tossed in the fire and his story will
end with him being burned alive
Melisandre always said death by fire is
the purest death what I think will
happen is right before Varys is killed
we will get the big reveal and find out
what was said in the flames that night
as varus's eyes are filling up with
tears because he knows his game is over
I think it would be incredible if
Melisandre Orkin Varro whispered in his
ear exactly what he heard in the flames
when he was a boy right before he has
burned alive
and we will finally get to hear what has
kept Varys terrified for all these years
and for some reason I just have this
feeling that Varys has known all along
what would eventually happen to him
that's why he was so scared when
kinvaras asked him if he wanted to know
what was said in the flames he didn't
want to know because he didn't want to
believe it would come true but when she
reminded him that the voice in the
flames was real he was scared to death
because he knew that it was real but
this is just my opinion and I could be
wrong so please comment down below with
your theory or questions or thoughts
because I would love to hear what you
have to say about this topic now let's
get on to the giveaway there is three
different prizes and there will be three
different winners and the name that I am
about to announce will get to have the
first pick between the three
prizes that I am giving away I did try
to record the screen as I click the
buttons for the website to randomly
select a name for the first winner but
it's kind of hard to see but if you
pause the video you might be able to
read it but I will show you the
screenshot of the first Prize winner of
the giveaway which is Kiara James
congratulations you are the first Prize
winner
all you have to do is contact me and let
me know which prize you want you get to
pick whatever option you would like do
you want the a song of ice and fire
collection the world of Ice and Fire
novel or the Game of Thrones Monopoly
game Kiara James you're gonna have to
message me with your address as well
that way I can send you whichever gift
you pick you can email me or you can
send me a private message on YouTube or
you can even message me on Twitter it's
totally up to you I will let everybody
know what surprise he picks that way you
know which two prizes are left available
to win so good luck to the rest of you
thanks for stopping by and watching the
video and thanks for participating in
the giveaway thus far and I'll also have
to give a big thanks to my patreon
supporters I love you all and I hope you
have a good day bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you